I guess all of you have in the
smartphone or an iPhone and this morning
probably you check on the weather if
it's going to be rainy to carry your
umbrella it's going to be sunny to use
your sunglasses it's going to be called
to have a extra cot it can give you some
time good information and sometime not
let me tell you my best app is my grand
mother she's call it mama
Ida she can't tell you not only to Dairy
weather but she can predict the next 12
months is it's going to be a good trend
season or not she can tell me just by
observing her environment by observing
the wind direction the cloud position
the birth migration the size of fruits
the plant flowers she can tell you by
observing the behavior of her own cutter
that's how she no better devera in the
ecosystem but she's live on it I'm
coming from a pastoris community who are
a title help us we are nomadic we move
from one place to another one to found
what and pasture we can move up 2,000
kilometers a size of California within
one year in this life help us to live in
harmony with our ecosystem we understand
each other for us the nature is our
supermarket where we can collect our
food our whare is our pharmacy where you
can collect our medicinal plant but it's
our school
where we can learn better how to protect
it and how it can give us back what we
need but with the climate change impact
we are experiencing a different impact
in my community we have one of the top
five freshwater in Africa it's the Left
chart when my mother get born lectured
used to be about 25,000 kilometre square
of water when i get born 30 years ago it
was ten thousand kilometres squares and
actually now it's about 1,200 kilometer
square of wallah 90% of this water just
evaporated disappear and you have more
than 40 millions peoples living around
dis left and depending on e they are
pastoralists they are fishermen and they
are farmers they do not depend from the
end of the month salary they depend from
the rainfall they depend from the crops
that growing or the pasture for them
petals the shrinking resources you have
many communities that fighting to get
access the first come is the first self
the second have to fight and to death so
climate change is impacting our
environment but changing our social life
because the role of man and woman in
this region it's different man supposed
to fit his family take care of his
community and if he cannot do that his
dignity is under threat he
cannot do anything else to pay it back
so climate change take our month far
away from us that is the migration they
can migrate to a big city where they can
stay for six or 12 months where they get
a job they can send back money if they
didn't get they have to jump into the
Mediterranean and be migrant in year
some of them died there but none of them
stopped going of course is sad for the
hosting country who are developed
countries who have to adapt to host the
migrant coming but how about those who
are left behind the woman and the
children who have to play the role of
man the role of women who have to take
care of the security of the food of the
health of the entire family children's
and all the people's so those women for
me they are my hero because they are
innovators they are solution makers they
are changing the little of the resources
into the big Fordham community so those
are my people so we use our indigenous
peoples traditional knowledge to get the
better resilience to what we need to
survive our knowledge are not only for
our communities is to share with each
and others who are living with us and
indigenous peoples around the world
serving 80% of the world by a diversity
that's the scientist with our indigenous
peoples in Amazon you can found the most
diverse ecosystem better than the
National Park the end
peoples from the Pacific the grandma and
the grandpa they know where to get food
after the hurricane hitting them so the
knowledge that our peoples know is
helping us to survive and help other
peoples also to survive if the climate
change impact world is is losing
we lost already 60% of the species and
is increasing every day so one day I
took a scientist to my community I said
you are given the good weather
information through the TV and radio but
how about coming to my people and then
they come they sit around and suddenly
as we are normally we just start packing
our stuff and then they say like are we
moving and like no we are not moving
it's going to be rain and then they're
like oh there's no cloud haja nice going
to rain and like yeah it's going to rain
we pack our stuff
suddenly heavy rain is tough honey and
you're seeing the scientists running
around hiding in the trees and then
taking them stuff
we already packed hours after the end of
the lens the serious discussions tab
they say how do you know that is going
to rain we say well just the old woman
observe
they are unset taking them eggs inside
them humps and wild and said cannot talk
or watch TV so they know how to predict
to protect the generation how to protect
them food so for us is the sign that is
going to bring in the maximum couple of
hours and then they say like well we do
have knowledge but we do not combine
ecological knowledge and where the
knowledge or together so that's how I
started working with meteorological
scientists peoples and my communities to
give the better information to get
people's adapt to the climate change I
think if we put together all the
knowledge system that we have science
technology traditional knowledge we can
give the best of us to protect our
peoples to protect our planet to restore
the ecosystem that we are losing I did
that in another way also I use a tool
that I really love a lot it's called a
3d perspective mapping hospital because
it can bring women mine use elders all
the intergenerational people's then it's
use a science based knowledge and
community come together they built this
map they figure out all the knowledge
that we have about where is our sacred
forests where is our water point where
is our corridors where is the place that
we move during each season and these
tools is amazing because it's build a
capacity of women because in our
communities woman and man cannot sit
together man talk always woman just
sitting there but in the back they are
not there to take any decision so after
the man figure out all the knowledge we
say well may you call the woman come and
have a look they say yes sure because
they already done the vessel when the
woman come and then they look at the map
they are like no this is wrong here
where I collect the medicine here where
I collect the food here when I collect
so we change the knowledge into the map
and we call the man what do you think
about what women say I love them
checking the head they are right they
are right they are life
so that's how we build the capacity of
the woman and giving them voice in this
3d part pattern mapping so women get the
detailed knowledge who can help
community to get other and man have the
bigger repair knowledge so when we put
it together this map help them to
discuss but to mitigate the conflict
that between the communities to access
the resources to chair better dis
resources to restore it and to manage it
for the long term our knowledge are very
useful indigenous peoples knowledge are
very crucial for our planet it's crucial
for all the peoples science knowledge or
discover 200 years ago technology 100
years ago but indigenous peoples
knowledge is thousands of years ago so
why we cannot put all these together
combine those three knowledge ease and
give the better resilience to the
peoples who are getting the impact of
the climate change and now it's not only
the developing country is the developed
countries also we saw the oricon we saw
they float around all the places we saw
the fire even here in California so we
need all those knowledge to come
together we need the people in the
center and we need the decision-maker to
change scientists tell them and we
taught them and we do have those
knowledge we have 10 years to change it
ten years it's nothing so we need to act
all together and we need to act right
now thank you
[Applause]
[Music]